the libs are coming for your parental
rights this viral clip care of our
friends at Libs of Tik Tok let's talk
about parental rights for a second
because it's become evident that it's
being used currently in this fight
against queer people and especially
queer kids who need more protections
than ever before like in catron and in
the US parental rights are being used to
thwart any rights of autonomy that the
kid might have and I'm sorry but kids do
have autonomy we've already established
this for example if a kid needs a blood
transfusion and the parents don't want
to it's not the parents right to refuse
that blood transfusion for that kid
because it is life-saving in the same
respect if a kid only needs to like use
a different name and pronoun in school
there might be a reason and a good
reason they're not coming out at home
and they need a safe place to be
themselves and so to hell with this idea
of parental rights when it comes to kids
who have their own consent and then
their own bodily autonomy and their own
autonomy to their personhood that need
to be protected to hell with this idea
of parental rights Libs 2024 to hell
with parental rights now you might say
who cares this is just some random
weirdo and that's true but we see the
same belief articulated by more
prominent less random weirdos here is
aoc's take on the gop's parents Bill of
Rights proposal they are ask asking the
Republican party to keep culture wars
out of classrooms our children need
urgent and aggressive educational
Solutions the American Library
Association coming out against this
Republican
proposal when we talk about Progressive
values I can say what my Progressive
value is and that is freedom over
fascism okay but it's AOC you might say
everyone knows AOC Is On The Fringe yeah
sure maybe but then here again we have
an even less Fringe even less random
even more prominent weirdo saying the
same thing Rebecca put a teacher's Creed
into words when she said there's no such
thing as someone else's child no such
thing as someone else's child our
nation's children are all our
children no such thing as someone
meaning there's no such thing as your
child they're all my child me Joe Biden
the libs are coming out in full force
against parental rights they view the
family as the final impediment to their
agenda on the bright side this is the
best line of attack that the GOP
currently has parental rights is exactly
what gave Republicans Virginia it's
exactly one of the reasons that Ronda
santis has been so popular in Florida
the libs know that dismantling the
family is unpopular but they also know
that they've got to do it to seal their
power and the scary thing is despite the
unpopularity they've already been pretty
successful at doing just that I'm
Michael nolles this is the Michael nlls
[Music]
Show welcome back to the show this
episode is brought to you by good
ranchers get great meat at a secure
price and 25 bucks off your order with
my code nolles you know what I had for
dinner last night I had some juicy
delicious succulent good ranchers as I
do many nights go to goodranchers.com
use code nolles K wle today and perhaps
that will give you some of Alisa's sweet
little Alisa's good ranchers recipes RFK
Jr potentially running third party and
he is weighing in on which major
candidate he's going to take more votes
from we'll get to that in one second
second first though Libs of Tik Tok
finding some real bangers lately she
always finds phenomenal clips that tell
you a lot about our politics but I don't
know the last few days that just been
hit after hit after hit here is
[Music]
one Speaking of the consequences of
liberalism there's this is the craziest
story that hit the news
yesterday and I I didn't really comment
on it directly yesterday because it was
so shocking I I didn't I felt it was
even distasteful to talk about it now
enough time has gone by I everyone's
already talking about it this guy Josh
Krueger is a liberal
activist and Josh
Krueger three days ago made fun of Scott
Adams the Dilbert comic and somewhat
vaguely conservative com commentator
who's a very interesting guy and has you
know obviously had a very successful
career Scott Adams three years ago
tweeted out if Biden is elected there's
a good chance you will be dead within
the year that was July 2020 three days
ago Josh
Krueger tweets out the Dilbert dude is
like no stradamus look at this
prediction from 2020 wow Eerie so he's
making fun of him he's saying yeah we're
all supposed to be dead and you know
we're not dead what an OT this guy is
and then two days after that Josh
Krueger was murdered in his Philadelphia
home and now the Dilbert guy is being
called
Nostradamus this is really weird we got
it's New York Times is reporting on this
Philadelphia journalist is killed in his
home Josh Krueger 39 was shot seven
times the police said that no arrests
had been made we don't know if the if
the people who killed him knew him or if
it was just another home Breakin like
there's so many of them in Philadelphia
so now people are saying wow Scott Adams
is predicting the future and it's weird
the timing is a little bit Eerie
obviously not for the reasons that Mr
Krueger
thinks I don't think that we should be
uh happy about this obviously I know
some people think they have a little
shod in Frey to here because the guy who
downplayed all of the risks of living in
these kinds of cities and downplayed the
spiking crime he ended up having to deal
with the consequences of that obviously
we should just pray for this guy's soul
and pray for ourselves too uh but what
do we make of Scott Adams does he
predict the
future no he only sort of Scott Adams
only sort of predicts the
future in the same way that prophets
predict the future people misunderstand
what a prophet is uh a priest friend of
mine uh father rutler has an excellent
line on this he says prophet do not
primarily predict the future but rather
see the
present they they predict the future
only in a derivative
sense in as much as telling the truth
will tell you something about how the
future is going to
unfold the number of murders in
Philadelphia has more than doubled over
the last decade it does not take a
Nostradamus to know that people are more
likely to be murdered in these cities so
some people deny that reality other
people just tell the
truth they just see the present they
tell the truth as they see it and when
when you tell the truth in an age that
is defined by
lies you're going to look like you're
predicting the future but you're not
you're just being honest with yourself
and making an observation and and also
having the Integrity to tell tell other
people that observation
too now
one place where you're going to
definitely want integrity and honesty is
when you're hiring people which is why
you got to check out zip recruiter right
now go to zip recruiter.com I would like
to give a hand to all those whose job it
is to hire from the small business
owners growing their team to the HR
directors hiring hundreds Across the
Nation you have one of the toughest jobs
there is hiring a good HR team is one of
the most important things you can do
with zip recruiter you can make your
whole hiring process faster and easier
zip recruit's powerful technology works
for you to identify people whose skills
and experience match your job zip
recruiter saves you Time by letting you
easily invite your top candidates to
apply to your job so they're more likely
to apply sooner zip recruiter is trusted
by over 3.8 million businesses for their
hiring needs Hiring Heroes let zip
recruiter help make your job easier for
out of five employers who post on zip
recruiter get a quality candidate within
the first day go to ziprecruiter.com
nscw to try zip recruiter for free that
is ziprecruiter.com
klees these guys are the best in the
business they make they are best in
business I guess because they make it so
easy for your business to hire
ziprecruiter.com k n
Wes speaking of lawlessness we've got an
update in the congressman Jamal Bowman
case your Congressman Jamal
Bowman is is the man who is a Democrat
from New York and he pulled a fire alarm
to stop the house from voting on a
continuing resolution and then he lied
about it and he said oh no I was just
trying to open the door the signs were
really confusing and I just didn't I
didn't know so this excuse fell apart
pretty quickly when we saw the alleged
signs there's one that says emergency
exit only it says emergency exit only
push until alarm sounds door will unlock
in three 30 seconds yeah and so but it
says alarm will sound emergency exit
only don't go out this way so unless
Congressman Jamal is completely
illiterate uh it's not convincing that
he would have not known what these signs
meant but then what's weird is in the
picture we have camera footage of him
pulling the alarm he's he's not standing
in front of those signs the signs are
nowhere really to be seen in that
picture apparently it's because he
knocked the science down and then he's
not pushing on the door he's just
pulling the fire alarm on the wall so he
he couldn't even pretend as though he he
thought it was just a way to get through
the door he He Turned turned and pulled
the fire alarm there furthermore the way
that you know his excuses complete BS is
because he didn't even go out those
doors Congressman Jamal apparently uh
ran out through a different door on a
different floor because he didn't want
to get caught because he didn't realize
that they had cameras in the US capital
tells you a lot about the caliber of
democrat Congressman so this this
totally fell apart and now what are the
Republicans going to
do if the GOP does not vote to expel
this man from Congress this man who who
did a much more egregious Insurrection
than anything committed by the hornh
Haack guy or the midwestern Granny's or
the Lecter fell from Florida smiling for
the camera Congressman Jamal
Bowman if any of those guys are guilty
of insurrection Bowman is guilty of it
20 times over if the G does not expel
him from Congress GOP is in charge of
the house right now then the GOP is just
completely impotent it's just completely
pathetic Bowman for his part is now in
damage control mode so he he sent out
this messaging according to Politico
which blamed everything on the Nazi
Republicans and he said we we've got to
we've got to stop these Nazi Republicans
from trying to make a big deal over my
pulling the fire alarm and obstructing
official Congressional proceeding when
Politico reported on the Nazi memo a
congressman Bowman then
backtracked and he he denied having sent
out the the guidance he said I just
became aware that in our messaging
guidance there was inappropriate use of
the term Nazi without my consent without
my consent I condemn the use of the term
Nazi out of its precise definition it is
important to specify the term Nazi
refers to members of the Nazi party and
neo-nazis which would be a lot more
convincing if Congressman Jamal Bowman
had not called me a Nazi on Twitter back
in March so back in
March after I gave my CPAC speech where
I said boys and girls are different you
know and Congressman Jamal tweets out
and says Michael this is a direct quote
Michael nolles is a Nazi hellbent on
keeping only white men alive and in
power and then he went on and on and
on so here Bowman insinuates I would
never use the term Nazi if I weren't
referring to German soldiers from the
1940s this was this happened without my
consent I completely disavow this I
would never do such a thing it's
terribly offensive oh yeah well was it
also accidental and non-consensual when
you called me a Nazi on Twitter the
tweet's still up was that still an
accident back in
March I don't know that I believe that
are you going to disavow that
Congressman Bowman are you going to
apologize to me are you going to
apologize to everyone for that that
awful decision no doubt made by some
low-level staffer to call me and for
saying
the he just keeps digging this is a guy
who is not thinking strategically and
this is one of the reasons also not to
lie it's bad to lie because lying is a
sin and can condemn your soul to hell
and you shouldn't do it for that reason
because it offends God uh but another
reason even if you don't believe in God
you don't care about your soul and if
you're just in politics another reason
not to lie is you're going to get caught
it's very especially when you're lying
publicly to the media in the age of
Twitter where there's a tweet for
everything you're going to get caught
man especially if you're not necessarily
the sharpest tool in the shed when
you're not maybe the
most uh highlevel makavelli metni kind
of political strategist out there and
then you start spinning all these lies
and denying and backtracking and you're
going to get caught and so probably what
would serve Congressman Bowman is for
him to stop speaking immediately two
days ago probably uh but but this is a
real
crime it's it's not it's not just that
he called me a Nazi or he called
Republicans Nazis and he's lying about
it and that's a little bit of a
political
Scandal obstructing an official
Congressional proceeding after the
Democrats have spent the last two years
whining and crying and screaming about
how January 6th was basically you know
the shots fired on Fort Sumpter I don't
you know give me a
break this guy if the GOP does nothing
here if the GOP doesn't seize on this
ADV Vantage and expel this Looney Tune
from Congress then what do we have the
GOP in Congress
for
now what do you have nasty particles in
your air for it's probably because you
don't have envirocleanse right now go to
EK
pure.com most people only think about
poor air quality when we have fires like
the ones that were just happening in
Canada America's evil Top Hat causing
New York to be a strange orange color
that made the air quality absolutely
Terri terrible have you stopped to think
about the polluted air in your
day-to-day life you and your family's
health might be affected by the air
quality in your home allergens and germs
floating in the air that you breathe can
make you sick but the good news is that
there is technology out there that helps
you purify your living space easily and
affordably with
envirocleanse you'll never have to worry
again envirocleanse is an inhome air
purifying unit designed to destroy cold
and flu viruses allergy inflaming toxins
mold and even more viral cleanse prom
promises far fewer colds allergies and
better sleep their air purifiers come in
all sizes colors and prices to fit every
budget and they offer additional
products like Surface Cleaner and
laundry detergent breathe in pure air
and live a healthier life visit EK
pure.com use code NES kwes for 10% off
your enviral cleanse home air
purification unit right now you will
also get their free air quality monitor
plus fast free shipping that is $150 in
savings EK pure.com Cod nles EK pure.com
promo code Nolls Faith Moore my friend
Faith Andrew claven very talented
daughter has written a new rendition of
the age-old Christmas classic A
Christmas Carol except this time it's
with a K it's a modern Twist on the
story of Ebenezer Scrooge except with a
female protagonist in a world where boss
babes are championed at the expense of
Family Faith is making the case that
having what matters is far better than
having it all A Christmas Carol now
available for pre-order order yours on
Amazon or wherever you get your books
today speaking of
Democrats RFK Jr seems poised to run
third party in 2024 so this raises the
question is he going to be a spoiler and
if he's a spoiler who's he going to be a
spoiler for is he going to be like Ross
perau and throw the election to the
Democrat or is he going to be like Ralph
nater and throw the election to the
Republican RFK Jr thinks he knows the
answer yeah but the and then the other
thing is that I take more votes from
president Trump than I do from President
Biden right so why would that help them
yeah it's not helping them
yeah I don't buy it I don't think that's
true I see why some people do think that
that might be true some people do think
that might be true
because uh RFK Jr is antix and he's
specifically anti-id vaac and a lot of
Republicans are also anti-id
vaac but that's pretty much
it RFK Jr I I kind of like the guy in
fact I grew up in his town his my my
grandmother attended Bobby Kennedy's
church for it's like 60 years of her
life or something I was a relatively
small town in Northern Westchester so I
you know I've been aware of Robert F
Kennedy Jr for most of my life and he
seems like an amiable albe somewhat
Ecentric fellow but he's a big lib other
than on the coid vaccines he's a lib on
pretty much every single issue he's a
lib on abortion he's a lib on energy
he's a lib on the climate policy such as
it is he's a lib on marriage he's a lib
on guns he's a lib on immigration he's
on the latter two issues he's a little
bit better than Biden and some of the
Dems but he's still a a liberal on those
issues so how is he going to take more
votes from Trump I just don't believe
that especially I know Republicans have
spent the last six months building up
Bobby Kennedy as a potential challenge
to Joe Biden to some good effect too by
the way because currently Bobby Kennedy
Jr is polling at 15% in the Democrat
Party which I think makes my case for me
and argues against the point Kennedy's
trying to make how is Kennedy polling
within the Republican party they haven't
taken a ton of direct polls on this
question there is one though here's one
this is one from Echelon insights shows
that Trump versus Biden right now
National poll has Trump winning by three
points 46 to 43 if the race
were Trump versus Biden versus
Kennedy Trump would win by four points
it would be Trump
40 Biden 36 Kennedy 14 so again the
margin of error is you know real here I
mean this it's pretty tight race as it
is but in as much as the polls show
anything it shows that Bobby Kennedy
would pull more from Biden than from
Trump the the the only issue is coid but
if coid were the defining issue of the
2024 race Ronda santis would be the
nomination
because Donald Trump has a million
pictures next to Anthony fouchy and
Ronda santis reopened Florida relatively
quickly that was that was his issue the
big issues that Define disantis are coid
first of all opening Florida up
relatively quickly and then parental
rights and fighting Disney and fighting
the the LGBT
agenda mostly it was Co but Trump is
still way up in the polls because
people's memories are short and there
are other issues that they're thinking
about So Co isn't the defining issue so
I I'm I say bring it on with RFK I'm
with it RFK has to I think argue that he
is primarily going to pull votes from
Trump because his base is still
Democrats the the people who like Bobby
Kennedy are maybe some eccentrics on the
right uh but more likely it's going to
be those liberals those Democrats who
think the woke people have gone too
crazy you know look I'm a Democrat I'm a
Kennedy Democrat all right I I love Jack
Kennedy all right I but I just think
these woke people have gone too far but
I still hate Trump so just needs some
you know Biden he's he's too old and
he's he's followed the left Fringe of
his party I just want to vote for a
Kennedy okay I'm going to vote for Bobby
Kennedy that's that's his Bas his base
is not rock ribed conservatives just to
use one example if you're pro-life you
can't in good conscience vote for Bobby
Kennedy because you've got a relatively
historically incredibly solid pro-life
candidate and Trump trump who got roie
Wade overruled Trump who was the first
president to speak at the March for Life
even if some recent comments have been a
little more confusing on pro-life uh
largely because he's trying to attack
his most formidable rival Ronda Sanz you
can't no one can seriously argue Bobby
Kennedy is more pro-life than Donald
Trump so you got a major candidate who's
pro-life who has got a way better chance
of winning than Bobby Kennedy does you
gotta vote for Trump or if let's say
Trump isn't the nominee it's Ronda
santis you gotta vote for Ronda santis
over Bobby Kennedy there's no there's no
real argument I say bring it on baby
let's go I want to see a Kennedy running
again speaking of trump and DeSantis
Trump is in hot water and Dan santis is
capitalizing on it because Donald Trump
just admitted that his promise to get
Mexico to pay for the wall was in a
certain sense at least a bluff so when
you hear these lunatics back there say
Trump didn't get anything from
Mexico well you know there was no legal
mechanism cuz I said they're going to
help fund this wall but there was no
legal mechan you know how do you go to a
country say by the way I'm building a
wall hand us a lot of money so Dan
santis is personally taking that clip
and not just from his campaign account
or his War Room account which has very
limited reach but is finally starting to
use his Rona santis personal Twitter
account which is much smarter his
campaign should have been doing that a
year ago has come out and said admitting
that the famous promise from 2016 to
have Mexico pay for the wall was just an
empty campaign slogan is bad enough what
makes it worse is that there is actually
a way to get Mexico to pay for the wall
impose fees on remittances sent to
Mexico and other countries by illegal
aliens as president I will get this done
no more Bluster results are all that
matter uh this is a good attack I don't
think that that Trump's admission there
is going to hurt him really all that
much I agree with what Trump said in
2016 which is that he could basically
shoot somebody in broad daylight on
Fifth Avenue and he probably wouldn't
lose a single vote I think that's true
because I think most people when they
heard we're going to get Mexico to pay
for it understood that to mean we're
going to get him to pay for it through I
don't know rewriting trade deals like
rewriting NAFTA for instance or through
potentially through remittances like
Governor Dan santis is suggesting or
through this or through that but I don't
I don't think most people understood
that to mean we're going to send an
invoice to Mexico and the president of
Mexico is going to pay for it still
though I think Dan santis is very smart
to pursue this line of attack I think
he's very smart to attack Trump from the
right I think some of the GOP consultant
class has wanted DeSantis to lay off
some of the cultural issues and to
present himself as I'm the Ane
alternative we're we're Team sanity over
here we're the we're not like those
crazy lunatic Trumper type people and I
I think that is just totally the wrong
framing that is GOP establishment donor
you know Chamber of Commerce nonsense
okay that's accepting the framing of JN
Stewart and Steven CBRE do you remember
uh about 10 years ago right around the
2012 race there was a rally to restore
sanity with these two liberal Comedians
and commentators John Stewart and Steven
coar because those tea party people or
those Sarah Palin type people they're so
crazy they're insane we're the sane
people okay and so for whatever GOP
consultant class types have convinced
Ronda santis to run as I'm the sane
candidate I'm not I'm not insane like
Donald Trump I think they large part of
the reason why Dan santis is in the
doldrums when it comes to the poll
numbers I think his best shot is to go
after Trump from the right from the
cultural issues the kind of cultural
issues that got Glen yunan elected in
Virginia that made Ronda santis popular
in Florida that the GOP consultant class
freaking hates but they're excellent
strong issues he needs to take the fight
to him and he his answer needs to be not
look I'm going to restore sanity and
Civility and we're not going to call
Mexicans murderers and rapists and we're
not going to force them to pay for any
wall his answer needs to be yeah we're
going to make him pay for twice as much
of the wall that Trump made him pay for
that's his only shot and it's probably
not going to work either because Trump
is so far ahead he's got such an
advantage he's practically an incumbent
he's 50 points up if you believe any of
the polls you know 40 40 to 50 points up
if you believe any of the polls so it's
still a long shot but I think DeSantis
is beginning to realize this is his only
shot he's not going to make peace with
Trump the die is cast they're enemies
now okay and so he can either he can
either just sort of fade away like many
of Trump's opponents or he can dig in
hit him from the right and then hope to
pop up at a later time either either
hope to win the nomination somehow or
pop up at another time when people
rethink the GOP and Ronda santis starts
to look like the real conservative
standard Bearer I think that's the game
he's playing right now GOP in 76
nominates Jerry Ford over Ronald Reagan
then Ronald Reagan gives a speech at the
RNC and I think a lot of Republicans
regretted nominating Jerry Ford because
Reagan gave this clear relatively more
conservative
political Vision if desandis is going to
have any shot that's his shot it's not
going to be this we're I'm I'm the sane
alternative okay I'm going to just
restore things to normaly no nobody
wants that man the normal status quo
that we had pre- Trump is the reason we
elected Trump because the normal is
extremely abnormal because the normal
these days is parents don't have any
rights and and we're going to upend our
whole political order and we're not
going to have any borders and that's if
that's normal we don't want normal okay
we want to shake things up now I I think
that's all a great strategy for disantis
that
said the race still isn't moving and
don't shoot the messenger on this
especially because I'm citing the
messenger Harris poll but I said after
that second debate I said Ronda santis
was the clear winner he did great
relatively to the other people on stage
and it's not going to matter the debate
just doesn't matter at all if the debate
did matter then it would help to santis
but the debate doesn't matter so it
won't
and please don't shoot the messenger
seems that I was correct according to
messenger
Harris uh the most Republicans ped
believe that Des santis won and also
that doesn't matter is the numbers
haven't really
moved the people are still just as
likely to support Trump or disantis or
any of the other candidates as they were
before the debate even though they
acknowledge that DeSantis won that
debate now speaking of electability for
the GOP moving past the candidates for a
second there's another another important
pull out that shows that voters favor
the
GOP on the economy by the widest margin
ever
recorded So NBC Li liberal poll shows
the GOP with a 21o lead over the
Democrats when it comes to handling of
the economy this poll goes back to
1991 this is the biggest margin
ever the question is will that be
reflected at The Ballot
Box all of these
indicators are showing that the
Republicans have a a strong Advantage
here if it were just one poll measuring
just one aspect of political life you
might say well the poll could be wrong
well you know maybe that aspect of life
didn't matter so much but consistently
here you see Trump versus Biden Trump
wins consistently you see on the
question of the economy the Republicans
beat the Democrats consistently on all
of these individual issues from border
security to parental rights to the
funding of the war in Ukraine
Republicans are on the popular side of
those issues Democrats are in virtually
every case Democrats are on the
unpopular
side so do you think that the
Republicans are going to win in 2024 I'm
not convinced of that just as I am
convinced that it's most likely that
Trump will be the GOP nominee I'm not
convinced he's going to beat Biden or
whoever the Democrat is
and not necessarily because of his
flaws I am not convinced that The Ballot
Box will accurately
reflect the the decision of the people
someone asked uh Michael if what group
did Trump underperform with in 2020 that
he's going to do better with in 2024 I
said I think the dead pretty sure I'm
convinced that Donald Trump severely
underperformed among the dead in 2020
especially in bellweather and you know
crucial counties and so I think that his
campaign needs to increase their
Outreach to the deceased
Community uh and all of the other
communities that are disproportionately
likely to vote by mail and in ballot
dropboxes that's that's a real issue
these are all really encouraging numbers
especially on the economy because people
do often vote with their wallets but
none of that matters it's the advice
that none of that matters if as FDR told
LBJ you don't sit on the ballot box none
of that matters if you don't have pole
Watchers who are making sure that
there's no fraud or in the case of the
advice of FDR to LBJ they actually he
was actually encouraging a little bit
more fraud which LBJ Then followed in
1948 and uh stole a senate seat and then
ultimately became president of the
United States so I don't think
Republicans should steal elections but
we got to make sure that the Democrats
don't you got to watch The Ballot Box my
favorite comment yesterday is from Noah
Hastings 6145 who says the microphone on
set is a great choice very classy but
kind of sucks that Michael is visibly
using a lav mic instead to find a mic
that's functional and stylish I will
tell you my friend it's true I'm wearing
a Laval mic here it's just a backup
mic this is this is this is my real
microphone uh that was not always the
case previously I had a mic it was a
real mic but it was kind of a dummy we
we used the desk mic as a backup and we
use the lav as the direct microphone but
now we've flipped it and this is very
troubling for me because I had gotten
used to gesticulating with my hands like
a wild Southern Italian and knocking the
microphone over and it didn't really
matter even though it would make our
audio engineer wins but now this is it
baby the golden microphone my last thing
that I did in La before I moved out was
I got to fill in for Rush limbo and sit
behind the golden EI microphone and the
only reason I wasn't able to fill in
more at that time was that my own radio
show was announced a few days later on a
different network but I was I got I got
to sit behind that I thought oh my
goodness the golden eib microphone Rush
limbo the king of talk radio and now
baby we've got the functioning gold
microphone right here on this desk it's
not the fully gold EI microphone there's
no other Rush limbo but it's a little
bit got enough gold
okay and speaking of gold boy what a
fortuitous transition speaking of gold
Costco has a new product that they are
selling out of and that is gold bars
I love this story I can't believe this
exists Costco has everything man they've
got $150 hot dogs with unlimited refills
of Diet Coke and nice little ground up
onions on it they've got free samples
you can make a brunch out of it they've
got massage chairs they've got chinos
and Oxford shirts they've got 50,000
packs of Seltzer they've got everything
and now they have bars of
gold that they are selling out of part
of the reason they're selling out is
because you you know this if you're a
Costco ficient auto as I am if you get
the slightly more expensive Costco card
then you get 2% back and apparently you
get 2% back on gold as well so you're
you're getting an effective 2% discount
on uh every ounce of gold you buy which
is pretty great but also what this tells
us is people don't have confidence in
the stock market this is an actual
political indicator the fact that Costco
can't stock gold bars fast enough is an
indicator that people don't believe the
stock market they think it's headed for
a crash I think it's probably headed for
a crash or at least a significant dip
that's going to affect the 2024 race as
well we we are still grappling with the
insane inflation that came to us by way
of coid lockdowns and Joe Biden's
massive spending and at the time the
whole time we were told that inflation
was not going to be an issue it that
actually they were going to curb
inflation that Joe Biden was going to
pass the inflation reduction act that
was going to curb inflation though it
didn't and all serious analyses on it
suggests that it either didn't affect
inflation or made inflation worse what
has thus far controlled inflation in to
the degree that it has been controlled
is the fed the FED finally raising
interest rates
but our economy is extremely precarious
right now and you can have all the
Geniuses on TV and their suits and ties
saying oh no everything's great Joe
Biden's doing fine it's the most
wonderful economy ever uh when people
stop stocking up on the gold bar then
I'll finally believe that speaking of
questionable finances uh the house is
investigating Joe Biden's bribes that he
would seem to have taken from lots of
countries around the world including
Ukraine and China uh they've now brought
a forensic accountant to testify uh
about how these sorts of crimes are
conducted does anything sound familiar
in this testimony Mr dubinsky you have
extensive experience as an expert
witness and consultant in the areas of
white collar crime financial fraud and
Corruption is it characteristic of these
types of crimes that actors hide behind
nicknames or other pseudonyms to master
their identity it's very common what
about this first email image is
characteristic of financial crimes that
you have investigated or provided expert
testimony on in the past well typically
you'll see code names used and and money
is being paid to somebody under that
code name uh and that's how these
processes work let me ask you something
you're you're very experienced when
conducting an investigation if your boss
prevented you from taking investigative
steps how would you react how would it
affect your findings first it would be
extremely troubling uh if I was told not
to continue to investigate something and
if I was put in that position I'd
probably withdraw from the investigation
so we know that the doj that Weiss who's
now the special counsel when he was
investigating the uh Hunter Biden really
Joe Biden scandal on bribes was styed at
crucial steps was said no you can't
really ask that question you can't
really go there we've heard this from
IRS whistleblowers we also know from
Hunter Biden's
laptop that Joe Biden was referred to as
the big guy the big guy hey we got we
got to send 10% to the big guy who's the
big guy are we talking about Al Capone
sort of I guess we're talking about the
Al Capone of the bidens which is Joe
Biden we now also know that Joe Biden's
brother Frank who has also made his
career just pedling his brother's name
and American influence Frank Biden has
referred to his brother as the big guy
when his brother calls Frank Biden will
interrupt business and say oh the big
guy's calling here's the big
guy and and you'll recall when when
Biden was first accused of this
impropriety what was the response from
Team Biden the response was show me on
paper where Joe Biden got a direct
payment from China or from Ukraine and
you're never going to see that Joel
might not be the swiftest person out
there but he's not a complete dummy okay
he he's at least is clever enough
politically to know how to cover his
tracks have holding corporations and use
code names so it's not going to say you
know okay here quar million dollars to
Joe Biden though they did set the the
Chinese did send $260,000 and a couple
wire payments to Joe Biden's home
address in Delaware so they didn't cover
it up perfectly but that's what this is
and the guy is obviously guilty
uh the GOP is going to keep digging in
on this there's going to continue to be
more drip drip drip leak leak leak
they've pulled the thread far enough now
I think and because the election is
Drawing Near and our enemies generally
tend to like chaos in our elections
probably you're going to get a little
bit more information out of China who
knows maybe you get a little more
information even out of Ukraine though
Ukraine is still counting on the bidens
to fund their War but but China I could
see them kind of messing around a little
bit or who knows which other
intelligence agencies have this kind of
dirt I mean the fact that Hunter Biden
left his his laptop at just some random
shop such that we got to see terabytes
of information who knows how many
intelligence agencies around the world
know about Joe Biden's crooked business
deals this is going to continue to look
worse for him throughout the election
does it look bad enough to replace Joe
Biden at the top of the ticket or is he
going to be able to hold on we're all
focused on the fight on the Republican
side there is going to be an
increasingly intense fight on the Dem R
side at least behind the scenes and
there's always going to be a Nome there
a a very short political Talent Gavin
Newsome waiting to jump in he's already
he's already dealt with the the open
senate seat in California quite well the
one vacated when Diane Feinstein died uh
there's a little little bit of a scandal
with that senate seat as well but we're
gonna have that's going to be my tease
you know I'm a big tease we're going to
have to wait for that until tomorrow
because today
is can I say it and can I say it on
YouTube today
is Tuesday so the show continues now you
do not want to miss it become a member
use code noes KW has a check out for 2
months free on all annual
[Music]
plans